Mm,
when you look at us,
us as humans,
as apes,
as primates,
as mammals,
when you look at some of the most
appalling realms of our behavior,
much of it has to do with the fact that
social organisms are really,
really hardwired to make a basic
dichotomy about the social world,
which is those organisms who count as us
and those who count is them and this is
virtually universal among humans and
this is virtually universal among all
sorts of social primates that have
aspects of social structure is built
around separate social groupings of
them's.
We turn the world into us as investors
and we don't like them very much and are
often really awful to them and the is.
We exaggerate how wonderful and how
generous and how affiliated and how.
Just like siblings,
they are to us.
We divide the world into us and them and
one of the greatest ways of seeing just
biologically how real this fault line
is,
is there's this hormone,
oxytocin.
Oxytocin is officially the coolest
grooviest hormone on earth because what
everybody knows is it enhances mother
infant bonding and it enhances pair
bonding and couples and it makes you
more trusting and empathic and
emotionally expressive and better at
reasoning,
reading expressions,
more charitable,
and it's obvious that if you just like
spritzed oxytocin of everyone's noses on
this planet,
it would be the garden the next day.
Oxytocin promotes prosocial behavior
until people look closely and it turns
out oxytocin does all these wondrous
things only for people who you think of
as an us,
as an in group member.
It improves in group favoritism,
in group parochialism.
What does it do to individuals who you
consider then it makes you crappy or to
them more preemptively,
aggressive,
less cooperative,
and an economic game.
What oxytocin does is enhanced this us
and them divide so that along with other
findings,
classical lines of us versus them along
the lines of race,
of sex,
of age,
of social,
economic class.
Your brain processes these us them
differences on the scale of
milliseconds.
A 20th of a second,
your brain is already responding
differently to an US versus them.
Okay,
so collectively,
this is depressing as hell.
Oh my God,
we are hardwired to inevitably be awful
to them's and them's along all sorts of
disturbing lines of,
Oh,
if only we could overcome these us,
them dichotomy's,
the worldly.
Oh No.
Are we hard wire to divide the world
along lines of race and ethnicity and
nationality and all those disturbing
things and what becomes clear is when
you look closely is it is virtually
inevitable that we divide the world into
offices and thems and don't like them
very much into treat them well,
but we are incredibly easily manipulated
as to who counts as an us and who counts
is of them and those fault lines that we
view as,
oh my God,
how ancient can you get that?
Say somebody of another race of volks
limbic responses in US commensurate with
they are them.
They respond,
they motivate automatic responses.
Oh my God.
Is that just the basic fault line and
then you do something like have faces of
same race versus other race and either
they are or aren't wearing a baseball
cap with your favorite team's logo on it
and you completely redefined who's in
us.
US is people who like the Yankees and
them are red sox fans and suddenly
you're processing within milliseconds
what damn baseball cap they haven't race
as being completely ignored.
Oh my God,
we are negatively hardwired to make
really distressing us that were
manipulated within seconds as to who
counts as us as event.
Good news with that,
we can manipulate us out of some of our
worst us,
them dichotomy's and recategorize
people.
Bad News.
We could be manipulated by all sorts of
audio logs out there as to deciding that
people who seem just like us really are
into.
They're really so different that they
count as of them.
Okay,
so fabulous study showing this,
this double edged quality to oxytocin
and this was a study done by a group in
the Netherlands and what they did was
they took Dutch university student
volunteers and they gave him classic
philosophy problem.
The runaway trolley problem,
is it okay to sacrifice one person to
save five runaway trolley?
Can you push this big beefy guy onto the
track who gets squashed by the trolley,
but that slows it down so that five
people tied to the attractive standard
problem at philosophy,
utilitarianism and justifies means all
of that.
So you give people the scenario and
people have varying opinions and now you
give them the scenario where the person
you push onto the track has a name and
either it's a standard name from
Netherlands.
Dirk,
I think who's like a peer to peer or
something which like if you're.
This is like a,
like a meat and potatoes Netherlandish
name or a name from either of two groups
that evoke lots of Zena phobic hostility
among people from the Netherlands.
Someone with a typically German name.
Oh yeah.
World War II.
That's right.
That was a problem.
Or someone with a typically Muslim name,
so now they're choosing whether to save
five by pushing dirt onto the track or
auto or Mahmoud and in general give them
those names and there's no difference in
how people would rate it.
Then if they were anonymous,
give people oxytocin where they don't
know that they've gotten it.
Controlled group has just placebo spurts
up their nose.
Give people oxytocin and Kumbaya.
You were far less likely to push dirt
onto the track and dirk is add,
you are now far more likely to push good
old auto or good old mom onto the rails
there and you are more likely to
sacrifice an out group member to save
five and you're less likely to sacrifice
an ingroup member.
All you've done there is exaggerate the
US than divide with that.